Here the solutions are 4 plus or minus the square root of 13. Great work if you
found those answers. Again, we start by moving this constant term to the right
side of our equation. So, we have x square, minus 8x equals negative 3. Next,
we want to add the same amount to both sides of our equation, so that we can
complete the square. Our b is negative 8. So, b over 2 squared equals positive
16. We add that amount to both sides, and then we rewrite the left hand side of
our equation using x minus 4 squared. Now that we have a perfect square, we
take the square root of both sides. To get x minus 4 is equal to plus or minus
root 13. We add four to both sides to get x by itself, so 1x is equal to 4 plus
or minus the square root of 13.